Salut les Mentalos !
Je rentre à l'instant même d'une date de tournée,
Et puis je viens de me dire :
"Tiens, c'est peut-être la bonne opportunité pour faire, pas vraiment, un vlog,
mais plutôt :  voici ce qui se passe quand je passe en tournée, durant 2 minutes chrono'
Je vais vous faire voir non pas la date que j'ai fait hier,
mais la date que j'ai fait il y a 15 jours,
j'étais au festival "Face & Si",
avec Marina Kaye et LEJ,
LEJ
: avec les filles.
Je vous mets uniquement les images dont j'ai les droits,
par contre restez bien jusqu'à la fin de la vidéo,
parce que après j'ai deux trois questions à vous posez
par rapport à la suite des vidéos de cette semaine et de la semaine prochaine.
Votre avis compte !!
"A quoi ressemble une journée de tournée ?"
Parce que là c'était vraiment une journée, je partais le matin
et je rentrais le soir
C'est Renaud Loiseau !
*brouhaha*
*chante le début de la musique de Rocky"
On espère qu'ils seront plus de 10
parce que sinon ça peut se voir dans la salle.
Diablo: Ah j'avais fait la coupe d'été
Joachim:  "Haha c'est classe"
Et ça se sont les loges !
Et Joaquim, t'es hors champs !
On te voit plus.
Ha ça c'est le tourbus pour la tournée de rodage
ou euh... ou pas.
*Marina Kaye fait chanter le public.*
*Marina Kaye et son groupe entament Homeless*
"elle sait faire"
— Mais quelle voix ! "
— T'as vu ça un peu !"
Diablo: "Bha alors on boit un coup ?!"
Fabien: " Ouhhh, mais dis donc, tu trinques avec les abonnés."
Diablo: "Ma meutz, ma meutz, tu as vu ma bonne meutz ?!'"
Fabien: " Et pendant ce temps là sur la scène."
*musique*
C'est ma deuxième partie.
J'espére que cette vidéo un petit peu différente
vous aura plu.
On est en milieu de semaine comme ça c'est pas
un truc où il faut trop réfléchir,
Et je me disais que ça pourrait être intéressant.
Bah si ça vous a plu vous mettez un pouce en l'air
sous la vidéo.
Voilà ! Alors j'avais quand même deux trois petites choses
à vous dire. Et surtout à vous demander.
Je sais si vous avez regardé la vidéo d'hier,
j'y annonce que je fais une vidéo participative avec vous.
Ça se passe sur mon Facebook, ma fan page Facebook "Fabien Olicard".
L'idée c'est que vous m'envoyez un "Mind Map".
Regardez dans la vidéo d'hier tout est expliqué y compris dans le descriptif.
Là j'en ai déjà reçu pas mal ils sont vraiment cool, mais ils sont hyper sérieux.
Si vous voulez envoyer un mind map décalé sur un sujet complètement what the fuck,
c'est complètement possible
Et puis ça pourra être cool aussi pour la vidéo.
Pour l'instant on est sur des trucs plutôt... carré .
En faisant cette vidéo aujourd'hui, un peu plus légère,
pour vous laisser le temps de respirer.
Je me disais: "tiens il serait peut-être temps de
relancer aussi les formats qui m'avait beaucoup plu de faire : les "true stories",
quand je vous racontais une anecdote de vie,
*rigole* d'ailleurs j'ai vu dans les commentaires aujourd'hui,
il y a marqué: " Nan t'es un gros mytho c'est n'importe quoi !"
Pas de problème.
Il y a aussi un format que j'avais fait 3 fois,
c'était mentaliser l'un d'entre vous par Skype.
Et bah j'ai bien envie de refaire ces deux choses là.
Alors vous me dites dans les commentaires déjà si ça vous tente,
et lequel vous voulez en premier.
Tant que vous êtes là je vous le dis :
Le meet up avance bien, il avance très très bien.
Je voulais aller dans un endroit spécifique
et j'ai une opportunité de ouf, je vous le dirai très bientôt,
mais ce sera début Octobre, à Paris.
Ça j'avais pas prévu de vous le dire dans la vidéo, mais comme ça vous savez.
Pensez à vous abonner, rendez-vous demain à 17h,
puisque le Mental Vlog, c'est, c'est tout ça !
Aller ciao !
Je joue mon spectacle en entier le 23 septembre à la Garenne-Colombe
C'est la date la plus proche de Paris si jamais vous voulez venir.
Sinon il y a toutes les dates de tournée sur mon site.